in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Darren
and Sasha are here hey guys how are you
Thank You great good welcome welcome
where you from Sacramento California
very cool welcome to Nashville and here
to do a debt-free screen absolutely love
it all the way from California how much
have you paid off one hundred and
sixteen thousand five hundred and eighty
three very heavy dollars I love it and
how long did this take you thirty four
months and range of income during that
thirty four months started at ninety
seven thousand and all the way up to one
hundred and twenty-three thousand very
cool what do you guys do for a living I
work for a non-profit after-school
program also work at a pizza place good
for you and I were I'm an audit analyst
over at a health insurance company and I
also work at a craft beer tap room you
you work at a chat room today craft beer
craft beer yeah that's kind of the same
thing craft beer tap room Chaplin just
kind of the same thing I'm sorry my I'm
deaf alright so a hundred and seventeen
thousand of heavy dollars and what was
that on Oh
the all-american dream of course we had
cars and school loans and a boat and
eleven credit cards and alone to some
family you were normal absolutely
absolutely no everybody's looking around
looking like their and almost broke and
you were looking normal and acting
normal and how long have you all been
married almost five years okay very cool
and so two years into your marriage
something happened what was the event
well I heard talk because I'm not really
good at telling stories because I never
finished the story we use Groupon
because we wanted to save some money got
a room in Sonoma for the weekend and
everything was paid for the room and we
get there and we spent bike we had all
the money in the world we bought wine we
went out each night and when we got home
we didn't have grocery money and at that
moment we kind of self checked and
realized that we needed to do something
we had gotten our taxes done and we're
told that we made ninety seven thousand
dollars we looked each other and said we
have nothing to show for that
and we had some friends Shannon and
George that were going through the
financial piece with some friends and
they started talking into our ear and we
I wasn't listening because I you know we
made enough money we didn't need this we
didn't need a budget I don't want to be
told what we could or couldn't spend
money on and the more and more
information we got our ears were opened
a little bit more and then we decided to
borrow the CD system and Darrin's
grandmother unfortunately had passed
away and we had a seven-hour drive to
get down to where the funeral was taking
place so we listened to your CDs the
entire seven hours there oh my lord
and we packed our laptop to do our first
budget in the evening the night before
the funeral in the hotel so we did that
and you fire hosed it man I mean all at
once go we were we were taken at all
that one time we were going to do this
get on board and the day after the
funeral we were told that we were going
to inherit $25,000 oh my god
and fortunately God knew we were not
ready to handle that amount of money
because we would have gone to Europe
because we weren't 100% into the
lifestyle yet of making sure we were
budgeting everything and fortunately we
didn't actually receive the funds and
how we were ready for that money I'm
gonna let Darren talk to you about how
we decided what to do with that money
well we didn't know what to do to the
money and I found you on Twitter because
I'm a bird nerd like yourself so I
tweeted you and you actually answered my
tweet whoa and you told us what to do
with the money and once we got that
answer we knew her on the right path in
the the baby step that we were on
babysit number two the next thing to pay
off was his student loans and it was
exactly twenty-five thousand dollars
just like that there so everything wind
up in the environment where I'm all
smiling because now I'm usually common
sense with her money
absolutely so she's in heaven grinning
and going yeah they're good good at
least that one got it right
very cool very cool and so that that
kind of put a little boost to what you
were already working on then put a
little rocket fuel on it and so what was
the hardest part of this process for you
all I think probably just not going out
to eat
we love traveling so not traveling we
did a lot more camping instead of hotels
and things like that we also had to sell
Darren's beloved truck after we chose to
how much was the truck we sold it for
14,000 when we sold it we paid off our
boat we paid up a couple credit cards
and we bought cash for the car I Drive
now so it was once I saw the money what
that truck will do it made sense to sell
and and it's not forever exactly now
that you're not broke and you make 107
thousand a year you can go buy a truck -
we will yeah that's very cool yeah very
good excellent excellent what was the
part of this that when you first started
when you're listening to those CDs and
you're going okay we got a day this kind
of got the eye roll and that's how
everybody starts and and you thought
Venice is gonna be so hard and then it
was easier than you thought what was the
thing that was easier than you thought
it was gonna be when you started for me
I think that once we put down all of our
money that was coming in each month on
paper I'm it made me feel like we gotta
raise like wow we really are okay we're
really going to get through this and the
budget was easier than you thought yeah
it perspective on how wasteful we had
been and it really has been the main
thing that's kept us going I'm a
spreadsheet girl so multiple
spreadsheets some versions of the
enthusiastically not yes okay some one
guy every day we know the nerd is in the
family okay every day we have a budget
meeting okay once a month need to review
this again just to make sure you're on
track yeah I love it
very cool well that that often comes up
because my daughter Rachel Cruise talks
about this in a talk she did recently
that the budget actually gives you free
and most people think having a plan is
going to take your freedom it's gonna be
so constricting but the good news is
you're in charge of it so you get to
decide what you constrict or what you
expand but you're just being an adult
and doing it on purpose instead of just
sitting there broke making 97 grand like
most people you were just normal as you
could be just normal as you could be so
you've really accomplished this
Herculean task of paying off a hundred
and seventeen thousand heavy dollars
what do you tell people the secret to
getting out of debt is budgets number
one without a budget without putting on
paper and having a purpose for it we
wouldn't know what to do but for me the
second one is communication I've always
wanted to say that this it's not doing
the financial thing together and the
debt with the other was fantastic but to
me it goes beyond the budget it's not
only about the money it strengthened our
communication is a marriage to
strengthen our marriage and I think it's
Sasha and I versus the world and what
went in yeah yeah you are good job well
done sergeant
I definitely think that the budget was
the main thing for me and I think
secondly to back up what Darren just
said that it it really took because I
was the breadwinner and really opening
my eyes to the fact that this wasn't his
versus mine and we combined our accounts
um and everything after we started
following your plan and that was
something I was really against for a
long time I had been married prior to
this you know yeah was very you know and
I think once we unified everything in
our marriage it really made sense of
this is the way a marriage works and it
was you know above and beyond just the
financials and anybody make fun of you
guys not necessarily fun of us that I
think just a lot of sideways looks and
well that's interesting and type of
different you're not you've lost your
independence now you're married you know
everybody's asking this is like well you
guys did that it's incredible how did
you guys do yeah
No yeah they may not do it but they at
least want to know yeah I love it very
cool all right Darren and Sasha they're
free baby Sacramento California one
hundred and seventeen thousand dollars
paid off in thirty four months making
ninety seven up to 123 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one we're dead free excellent well done
well done well done man that's good
stuff
so you want to get on a budget like that
jump on every dollar calm it's a free
online budget tool the best there is out
there anywhere did I mention it's free
takes about ten minutes to do your
budget and there's a free iPhone app to
every dollar hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind